[Music]
bag remake studio
in shonen japan repairs designer bags
and accessories
[Music]
this 800 monogram wallet is an
unmistakable louis vuitton staple
the owner uses it on a daily basis and
now the lining is deteriorating
the leather is discolored and the paint
is peeling on the edges
one of the studio's repairmen will show
us how they restore this wallet
by taking it apart repainting it
creating new linings
and stitching it all back together
first the artist takes the bag apart in
order to work on
each piece separately
he uses a seam ripper to carefully take
out the thread
after he takes off the outer shell of
the wallet he uses a sewing owl to take
out the internal threads
[Music]
next he'll move on to fixing the
severely discolored leather
he starts by color matching the brown
shade of the wallet
this shade is made by combining black
yellow
red and white leather paints
[Music]
once he has a perfect match he uses a
paintbrush to slowly start coating the
discolored parts of the leather
won't touch the signature monogram this
preserves the authenticity of the piece
[Music]
after years of rubbing against money the
interior lining
needs to be replaced the customer
requested a nylon lining
[Music]
to do this the repairman cuts out the
new lining with a sharp
knife using the exterior of the wallet
as a stencil
[Music]
he coats the wallet in glue and presses
the new lining onto each piece
once the piece is dry they are ready to
come back together
the artisan sews them slowly carefully
ensuring
each stitch goes into the exact same
hole as the original
[Music]
once the three main pieces of the wallet
are assembled the artisan
glues and sews them together
[Music]
[Music]
to finish this repair he paints the
edges of the wallet where it's peeling
with an edge coat
[Music]
this ensures that all of the wallet's
corners are sealed
the final step is to hand rub the whole
wallet with mink oil
which will prevent the leather from
peeling or getting discolored
and will extend its life for years to
come
[Music]
you